برقص والزغاريد وتوزيع الشربات استقبل
جمهور مسلسل جعفر العمده نبا براءته من
التهامي المنسوب اليه ايضا عروض في بعض
المحلات وهدايا خاصه لكل من اسمه جعفر
ولافتات معلقه في الشوارع تبارك لبطل
العمل محمد رمضان على براءه ما هي هذه
الخلطه الشعبيه التي خلقت هذا التفاعل
الجماهير الكبير مع هذا المسلسل
[موسيقى]
احنا كنا هنوزع شربات في الشارع ده
وزغاريد بقى ودنيا بقى كانت الدنيا حلوه
الصراحه لا هو راجل محترم
حلو كويس ان هو طلع براءه كان لازم يطلع
براءه اصلا بطل المسلسل وبتاع لو مخدش حقه
انا هنزل اجيب حقه كل اللي جعفر بس انا
عارف ذكي هو
عارف المسلسل معروف اصلا المعلم جعفر طلع
بالسلامه وان شاء الله يرجع ياخذ حقه فتح
الله واحنا ورا ورا جعفر العمده لحد لما
يعرف ان سيف ابنه يجيب حق باذن الله
[موسيقى]